[Music]
this year the nba is celebrating its
incredible 75-year history the league
recently brought together some of the
most iconic athletes to ever set foot on
the hardwood and we caught up with a few
of them in cleveland 83 year old hall of
famer oscar robinson is one of the
greats he also helped change the game
both on and off the court nba champion
dirk nowitzki he was born and raised in
germany and spent all 21 years in the
nba with the dallas mavericks and hall
of fame sharpshooter ray allen renowned
for his three-point shot and he's also a
two-time nba champion we spoke about the
league's global influence and their
personal stories of success and failure
and also how their activism has inspired
millions of kids
one day i got the phone calls and they
said that you're on the 75th team here's
adam with a deep three yes and i was
like wow really
i couldn't believe it because
as a kid i remember where i was when i
really saw my first nba game do you
remember that game yeah what game it was
it was the bulls mix i just remember the
move that the mj made he came down the
lane he turned to the defender and then
he hit him and then he made the layup
going underneath the basket i thought to
myself
wow i like this game
where i come from and germany is not
really a basketball country and when i
came here i was 19 20 i'm sure about
whether i was going to make it in the
league one of my first home games was
against houston at the time and they had
scottie pepper and charles and hakeem on
the same team
i'm like a kid in the candy store i
loved all of these threes and 90s
watched them so that was an unbelievable
moment for me like i'm here with with my
idols but you guys all have something in
common
there's this
love for the game
this love for the craft the process of
wanting to be great but
was there a moment when
it clicked and you thought to yourself
i can do this and i can do this at a
high level
for me no i was taught years ago there
was always somebody out there
that can clean your clock eventually
and so i worked on my fundamentals and
worked on play i just loved the
competition i didn't feel anything that
i was any better than anybody else i
used to watch players and see what
they'd do see demons to me is action
reaction with the subtleties right well
you got i know you're playing against i
mean like jerry west was the logo if he
got the shoot he's going to make it you
know bart frazier was tough on defense
russell liked the black shots you were
an advocate for protecting players
financially but also you stood for
social equality you played in a time
where let's just be honest
it wasn't easy to be a black man in
america well no but you know but i think
sports i once said that
the greatest event for me was the
olympics i'm on a stand with jerry west
i said man how the hell would get here
i said i was born in tennessee i said
man this is the greatest thing i've ever
experienced in my life you're up there
you hear the natural anthem man that
goes all through you
it was something i would never ever
forget ray allen from the university of
connecticut it is october 15 1996. so i
get drafted earlier that year in june
1996 and it said first game minnesota
timberwolves second chicago bulls united
center october 15
1996.
and you know i've never met michael
jordan before in my life right and so i
was you know i was scared to death
thinking what was i going to be able to
give to the game because you're a fan of
jewelry yeah still posters on this wall
on my wall like wearing shoes like all
this and i'm like i'm about to play
against the greatest that i've ever seen
and so
that that day comes we're in the united
stand i just remember sitting on the
court i was stretching and then the
whole song comes out and i was like man
i'm really into tv right now
yeah i've been hearing this this opening
montage of the bulls stampeding through
on the jumbotron and now i'm seeing and
he runs down the floor 6-6 yeah north
carolina wow
[Music]
looking back at it now
a kid from germany
idolizing nba players and then becoming
one of the greatest how does that feel i
wasn't the most confident guy so when i
first got here i was i was nervous am i
going to last through my rookie year do
i have to go back to europe dirk do you
have a statement you want to make
no no no
pass me the ball
[Laughter]
that first year was big and it showed me
if you work hard and you keep at it
you can you can make it in this league
ray the nba
is
woven in the fabric of everything
culture
clothes music and seeing what basketball
means to the culture of society
how do you explain that i think
explaining my journey means i have to
explain the journey of the players that
came before me so i get to talk about
big o and magic and dr j and mj and
kareem
what does basketball mean to you
i mean it meant everything it was my
whole life
it gave me so much i mean when i was 12
13 years old i'm traveling through
europe and playing in these youth
competitions and my friends haven't even
left my hometown yet for me basketball
is magic and i hold it in my hand
whenever i'm sitting with kids and i say
you see this ball you guys think it's
magic
and then you know
eighty percent of the kids look at and
say no it's not magic and i said well
let me tell you what it can do
you know as you're sitting here staring
at it it's not moving
but if you commit to this thing and you
dribble it you shoot it you you commit
to it every single day it's going to
take you to places you couldn't imagine
timmy is a way of life
got me out of the ghetto got me into the
university of cincinnati to get an
education
uh and it got me to
raise it to see see all over the world
but but it's a way of life it changes
you it changes your outlook on things
you know i love sitting down with those
legends and i love what ray allen said
you see this ball yes it's magic it's
not moving commit to it if you shoot it
and you dribble it every day yeah it
could take you places that you have
never been i thought that was an
incredible statement for kids to hear
yeah but i mean not only but a
basketball you can take it to any walk
of life yeah that instrument that book
that pack
it's just really well put from ray allen
you know what i liked i liked hearing
the insecurities that they had
to ray allen painted such a great
picture so did oscar started they all
did actually to go from where they came
from to be who they are today that's
what i thought was so cool no matter how
great you are at something i will give
some some advice to kids out there what
is it live with humility because these
are the most humble superstars that's
the game has ever seen did you tell me
any of your glory day stories no state
washington i was all state
yeah but high school all right get out
of here
enough about you let me tell you about
me
i'm really good that was great though
nate i really enjoy that conversation